en el vídeo anterior les presenté la
idea de la regla de la cadena usando
derivadas parciales y dijimos bueno si
yo tengo una función sí que es una letra
griega y ésta sí depende de dos
variables xy de y si quiero tomar la
parcial con resto no perdón no quiero
tomar la parcial quiero tomar la
derivada de eps y respecto de x esto
será igual a la parcial de epsy respecto
de x más la parcial de pepsi respecto de
iu y luego multiplicado por la derivada
de y respecto de x ok y en el último
vídeo esperemos que haya quedado un poco
de intuición créanme tal vez algún día
voy a probar bien esto de la regla de la
cadena pero si no pueden buscarlo en
internet ok por si están interesado en
el tema de la de las derivadas parciales
y utilizando la regla de la cadena
entonces ya estamos listos para resolver
las ecuaciones exactas la intuición es
un poco
no quiero decir difícil porque si tienes
la intuición pues la tienes pero bueno
lo que pasa es lo siguiente digamos que
tenemos esta función sí y vamos a tomar
la derivada parcial de epsy con respecto
a x primero ok no vamos a seguir
escribiendo que depende de xy de y
simplemente lo pondremos así y ahora
vamos a tomar la derivada parcial de
esto respecto de y ok esto simplemente
como notación nos va a quedar en
términos de operadores digamos como el
parcial cuadrado de pepsi respecto de y
ok respecto de x donde esto es como una
de ree sarita o algo así y también puede
escribirse con otra anotación que no
tiene toda esta basura de letras a mí me
gusta más que es
si su x que es derivar primero respecto
de x a la función sí y luego respecto a
y ok ahora qué sucede cuando tomamos la
parcial respecto de x y luego respecto
de y ok es decir recordemos que cuando
derivamos respecto de x todo lo que
involucra ye se queda como constante y
al revés ok ahora cuál es la diferencia
si cambiáramos el orden es decir qué
pasaría y déjenme escribirlo con otro
color qué pasaría si primero yo derivo
con respecto ayer y luego derivó con
respecto a x ok entonces nuevamente como
notación esto es la parcial de segundo
orden respecto de x respecto de i y esto
es en términos de operadores y podría
ser un poco confuso aquí verdad porque
como que el orden se invierte de este
lado estamos pensando en el lado derecho
que primero derivamos respecto x y luego
derivamos respecto a y de este lado
estamos pensando en operadores como si
fuera una multiplicación de ellos
correcto ok de todos modos vamos a
también escribir esto como la parcial
perdón si su ya y luego x ok
y ahora voy a decir que que si cada uno
de los primeros parciales son continuas
es decir la parcial de epsy respecto de
x y la parcial de eps y respecto de y en
algún dominio sin agujeros y que
realmente sean continuas en ese lugar
este tipo de funciones continuas son las
más comunes en un primer curso de
cálculo diferencial cierto entonces si
estas dos funciones son continuas nos
referimos a las primeras derivadas
parciales de pepsi ok entonces estas dos
van a ser iguales entre sí es decir si
sub x es igual a pge y sub
x ok ahora vamos a utilizar este
conocimiento junto con la regla de la
cadena que dijimos en el vídeo anterior
ok
y esto que acabamos de observar ok esta
igualdad para decir qué tipo de
ecuaciones diferenciales son las exactas
ok y cómo es el aspecto de una ecuación
exacta ok ahora una ecuación exacta
tiene el siguiente aspecto siempre
elegir el color es la parte dura del
vídeo pero bueno digamos que tenemos una
función m que depende de xy de ye puede
ser x cuadrada x coseno de hielo que se
ok y luego le sumamos una función n que
también depende de xy de iu y
multiplicamos por la derivada de ye
respecto de x y que esto nos diera 0
bueno esto aún no es una ecuación exacta
todavía pero tiene alguna forma que
debemos distinguir bueno en realidad el
primer impulso debería ser oye esta
ecuación es separable porque si es
separable a través de álgebra o lo que
sea podemos resolverlo de una forma más
fácil pero si la vemos como decimos si
es una ecuación exacta
este patrón aquí parece bastante
horrible pero es muy parecido a lo que
tenemos de este lado de arriba
qué pasa si m fuera la parcial de sí
respecto de x ok la parcial de epsy
respecto de x es m y qué pasa si la n
fuera la parcial de eps y respecto de y
ok parcial de epsy respecto de ella sólo
estoy diciendo que esto pues no va a
suceder al azar digo no va a ser siempre
es cierto pero qué tal que sí que tal
que de repente m es la parcial de una
función respecto de x quien es la
parcial respecto de y si esto fuera
cierto entonces la ecuación toma esta
forma la parcial de epsy respecto de x
más la parcial de pge y respecto de y
por la derivada de ye respecto de x
igual a 0 y esto es exactamente lo que
teníamos arriba ok esto simplemente es
la derivada de pepsi respecto de x
usando la regla de la cadena así que así
podemos reescribirlo esto es la derivada
respecto de x de una función sí que
depende de xy de iu y esto es igual a 0
y ahora si ves una ecuación diferencial
y esto de casualidad tiene esta fórmula
y te dices oye chico pues no puedo
separar la bueno vamos a intentar a ver
si es una ecuación exacta y francamente
si lo encontramos de esta forma
probablemente podamos resolverlo ok
entonces si es una ecuación exacta vamos
a mostrar cómo utilizar los principios
que hemos encontrado anteriormente para
llegar a esta fórmula ok en donde está m
sería la parcial respecto de x y en la
parcial respecto de ella entonces si se
puede escribir de esta forma obtenemos
una primitiva de ambos lados y entonces
escribimos que si es igual a una
constante ok y esa sería la solución ok
hay dos cosas que debemos preocuparnos
primero podrías estar diciendo ok
a ver ya te metiste con el rollo de eps
y las parciales y todo esto pero como sé
que es una ecuación exacta y si ahora sé
que es una ecuación exacta entonces cómo
resuelvo esto para así así que la forma
de averiguar esto es utilizando esta
información que tenemos de este lado
sabemos que sí y sus derivadas son
continuas sobre algún dominio entonces
cuando tomes la parcial con respecto a
equis y luego hay con respecto a y es lo
mismo que hacerlo en el orden inverso ok
por lo que hemos dicho anteriormente
sale de este lado vamos a marcar estas
dos cosas ok entonces si esto es una
ecuación exacta muy bien entonces está m
será la parcial respecto de x y n serãa
la parcial respecto de y vamos a ver qué
pasa si tomamos las derivadas de la m y
la n primero si de x es igual a m si
tomamos la derivada parcial respecto de
i íbamos a
ponerlo así esto debería ser exactamente
igual que la derivada de n respecto de x
ok porque fíjense en lo siguiente si su
pie es igual a n y si ahora derivamos
respecto de x ok ponemos como subíndice
x entonces sabemos que la parte de la
izquierda es igual ok
porque sus parciales son continuas sobre
el dominio que ya elegimos entonces la
parte derecha también será igual por lo
que este es realmente la prueba de cómo
sabemos si es una ecuación exacta así
que permítanme reescribir todo de nuevo
así que si vemos algo de la forma m que
depende de xy + n que depende de xy de y
por la derivada de y con respecto de x y
esto es igual a cero entonces tomamos la
derivada de m con respecto de i y luego
tomamos la derivada de n con respecto de
x ok si estas dos son iguales entonces
estamos hablando de una ecuación exacta
de hecho es un sí
si ok esto será una ecuación diferencial
exacta
si es una ecuación exacta nos dice que
existe una sí que depende de xy de y ok
tal que la deriva con respecto de x de
essap sí que depende de xy de g
es igual a cero o equivalente mente que
si es igual a una constante esta
ecuación y la derivada parcial de sí con
respecto de x es igual a m y la derivada
parcial respecto de y es igual a n es
igual a n ok ahora voy a mostrar en el
siguiente vídeo cómo utilizar toda esta
información para resolver la ecuación de
pesic ok esto será la derivada al
respecto de x xxi ok pero cuando tomamos
este tipo de prueba lo tomamos con
respecto a iu
a ver si es igual a la derivada respecto
de x de n que en este caso la n sería la
parcial de epsy respecto de iu y así
tendríamos las las derivadas mixtas de
todos modos sé que a lo mejor podría
estar un poco complicado pero sé que si
entendiste todo lo que hice en este
vídeo tu intuición sobre las ecuaciones
exactas será excelente nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo donde podrás ver algunos
ejemplos de las soluciones de estas
ecuaciones